let's talk about the Brazilian economy
you had the central bank cut the
interest rate by 75 basis points
yesterday you had the IMF reducing its
growth forecast to 0.2% when do you
expect to see robust growth of the sort
that you've talked about
we are expecting groped to start this
quarter and we'll be accelerating
throughout the year if we compare the
provision for the last quarter of 2017
this year with the last quarter of last
year expectation today is around 2%
growth last quarter against last quarter
and but for the whole year what sort of
number do you expect if you compare
average against average it's a low
number because of the very deep
recession yes and then the statistical
carry over brings the number down by one
percent that means that estimation
estimate is in the market there's about
half percent IMF has a lower number yes
you would expect to bring your number
down closer to the IMF number or closer
to the BOC now we are going to revise it
basically in about two weeks time but
lower than the one percent you would
expect that's that you wait and see
yes can we look at another number the
the interest rate currently around 13%
president temer has talked about that
coming down to a single digit you know
in bits what would be a reasonable guess
for when it gets down to single digits
is it two years away is it five years
away what would be what's your what's
your internal target for when you expect
that interest rate to come down below
ten percent well
we don't have a specific target for the
trade to have a target for inflation and
evidently inflation is coming down
strongly which has enabled central bank
to take steps on cutting the interest
rates in a faster pace but evidently we
have to watch inflation carefully
because this the key here is to anchor
expectation inflation expectations and
having established that firmly dam
central bank would be able to really
keep gradually calm down would you
expect to see more drops at the 375
basis point level that's not to talk
about what central bank is going or
should do because when I was a governor
of this about finance ministers talking
too much about what I should what about
in a pension reform Social Security
reform that is with the Congress at the
moment do you expect that to get through
it's worth maybe 200 billion dollars a
year to the state finances but dude did
you expect that to get through well our
expectation is that it's going to be
approved by the House of Representatives
by the end of March early April and
eventually approved by the Senate in
late May early June
that's I think a reasonable expectation
and is there a kind of compromise that
could be hashed out that still seems to
be a difference between the government
and the Congress Wow
Social Security reform is a
controversial one it's subject to very
heated debate all over them all over the
world the horror may take space it's
normal but there are some critical
points which are firmly established like
a minimum age 65 years life for men and
women yes and also some transition
period and
etc and also we'll we are going to
hopefully to eliminate the double
patient yes people get fashioned because
they they are they have a deceased
spouse and at the same time because they
retired this kind of thing but you you
must you are famously prudent man you
must have a plan B somewhere for what
you do if you cannot get pension reform
you need to do something to get money to
come into the government does that mean
you you you need to tax what is the plan
B well if Social Security is not
approved there before which I think it's
going to be because it has to and we
have a very good example now in the
state of Rio where Social Security is
insolvent and has there is a need to
raise contributions dramatically for
retired people that's not good and
that's a good example I think that
that's going to go through if for some
reason it doesn't go to complete or as
it should then there are several other
measures number one to cut expenses in
having several other benefits which
could be cut number one fiscal
scientists also withdraw withdraw and
evidently in the last resort
raising taxes when do you think Brazil
will get its investment grade back again
my theory about that is that I do my job
the rating agencies do their job you
must have some you must have somewhere
an idea about when you think that would
be possible I hope the sooner the better
but I hope that's that before 2018 2018
you just mentioned it we have we have
the election coming up you know to what
extent is president a man saying he is
not gonna run again a handicap does that
make it harder to deal with the Congress
now I think it makes it easier because
it it opens the field and all the
several parties which who have
candidates at cetera they'll not be
world about president Turner running and
they'll not be hesitant to support him
in his basic agenda reform because we
are doing the tough job and that would
make life much easier for people who get
elected next year can I ask you one last
question she was an obvious one falling
home for that you you are you know one
of the straight men of Brazilian
politics people sometimes talk about you
is somebody who would run for president
would you think about doing that next
year in 2018
what I am is getting the Brazil economy
right on track and having Brazil in the
future belongs to the future and I would
be right to read that as it may be no
simply the fact that I am focused on
doing my job today